there's been quite a lot of discussion
over the last two or three weeks about
uranium enrichment in connection with
various nuclear plants that have been
built around the world including in Iran
so it seems to me that many people may
not really understand why you should
want to into really enriched uranium or
what it involves
first to explain the enrichment process
there's going to be a little bit of
explanation about the sort of core
science behind it at the heart of the
problem are so called isotopes you've
got all the elements in the periodic
table and what makes each individual
element different to another element is
its atomic number
now for uranium that's 92 and what that
means is that there's 92 protons in the
atomic core and each of those has a
little positive charge on it
and this is a very very tiny amount of
space that these protons are in now
normally you wouldn't want a load of
positive charges in one space because
they do repel each other and in such a
tiny space they'd really try and fly out
so nature came up with a way of
buttressing the charges between
individual protons and it did this with
little particles called neutrons and
because they have no charge it is
sometimes possible to have different
numbers of neutrons without changing the
element now the two main isotopes of
uranium which we have interest are u-235
and u-238 and that basically means that
the u-238 has got three extra neutrons
in the core compared to the u-235
isotope now in terms of radioactivity
and generating nuclear power or causing
a nuclear explosion uranium-235
is much more explosive it will absorb
neutrons and can blow apart releasing
energy then uranium-238 the problem is
that if you dig uranium out of the
ground as it comes naturally you have
99.3% of uranium-238 and only 0.7% of
the uranium-235 so now we come to
enrichment what enrichment means is
taking a sample of uranium and
increasing the amount of uranium-235
to the amount of uranium-238 if you
think about it what this means is that
you have to separate off some of the two
three eight and throw it away and the
two atoms are chemically identical so
you have to separate them by some sort
of process that depends on their mass
and to make matters worse you can't
separate it's difficult to separate the
naked atoms so you have to put the atoms
into a compound usually the compound uf6
uranium with six fluorine atoms around
it which is even heavier and then you
have a difference in mass of three
between these two compounds and the
original way of enriching uranium which
was used during the Second World War in
the Americans Manhattan Project was to
take a material that had fine holes in
fact it was the plastic Teflon and the
uranium-235 diffuses finds its way
through sheets of this material slightly
faster than uranium-238 nowadays what
people use as so-called
centrifuge a centrifuge is a cylinder
cylindrical container that is spinning
very very fast and the gas is spun round
very very quickly and you all know like
if you want to swing of a merry-go-round
you want to go outwards because of the
centrifugal force well that happens in
this system and the heavier to 3/8 gets
pushed to the outside and the lighter to
3/5 all blocks up in the middle so in
the center here you put some sort of
inverted cylinder with a tube and so the
gas that comes out round the edges has
slightly more to 3/8 and the one in the
middle has slightly more to 3/5 now in
each centrifuge in one centrifuge the
effect is very small so you need to use
literally thousands of these centrifuges
where the output of one is fed in
the bottom of the next and gradually the
amount of uranium-235 will go up and up
and up and at the same time the material
that you take out at the bottom of the
system will have progressively more and
more and more uranium-238 now much of
the argument about whether the country
is trying to make bombs or trying to do
make fuel for nuclear power depends on
the amount of uranium-235 compared to
238 for making weapons you need much
more 235 because you want to release all
the energy at once from quite a small
mass then if you're trying to do nuclear
power where you want the energy to come
out steadily over a year or so so you
can generate electricity and it needs
real experts people far beyond me to
tell whether a particular plant is
designed for making weapons or for
making fuel of course at the end of the
other end of your enrichment plant you
get a lot of uranium which has the 235
almost completely removed this is called
depleted uranium this is just uranium
turnings in a jar they're under oil to
protect them the vast majority of that
uranium is the isotope to 3/8 this is
depleted which will come on into a
little bit so only about no point not
two percent of it is 2 3 5 depleted
uranium is an extremely heavy and dense
material and has a variety of uses
people use depleted uranium as weights
inside aeroplanes every plane needs a
small weight I think it's at the front
just to balance it if you make it out of
uranium-238 it takes that less space
than if you make it out of laid or
copper or something like that and of
course uranium-238 depleted uranium is
what is used in chemistry labs for
people who are studying the chemistry of
uranium because it's an advantage when
you'll handle
if the material is has lower
radioactivity as possible
that's that explanation you gave of
uranium enrichment sounded very simple
why can't everyone in which uranium why
can't you here at the University of
Nottingham in rich uranium well there
are a number of reasons first of all you
need a huge plant secondly in order to
get an effect your centrifuge has to
spin enormous ly fast so it has to be
made that of extremely special metals so
that the actual can doesn't fly apart
I think the like a lot of things in life
the basic idea is really simple but
actually executing it
so you don't end up with clouds of
radioactive uf6 pouring all over the
place is actually not trivial and you
need something that will did the plant
will use a huge amount of electricity
and handling fluorine to make uf6
is chemically quite difficult handling
the vapor of uranium and fluoride uf6
is extremely difficult and so it's only
possible for in a very large company or
a nation to do this it's quite beyond
the capabilities of any individual or
even individual University